for coming for the second second our
first speaker in the second session is
Priscilla kilmury who is also the second
speaker of the session how is reputation
is in the control community is very well
known very large body of work so welcome
Richard Charlotte well I should be here
of course and to tell you a little bit
about this area so let me just say what
I hope you get out of this talk - my
goal here is of course like the two
talks in the morning to get a little bit
overview of this area for people who
aren't familiar with it and to talk some
about how this might be relevant for
applications in real time decision
making and of course the quite a broad
set of applications that we're thinking
about in the context of the real-time
decision-making program so that's a
particular challenge but of course
really all I'm going to do is you know
hopefully tease you with some ideas
about oh that's interesting that's a
different way to think about it or
that's a feature that I see present in
my problems and so maybe control theory
can shed some light or provide some
tools or whatever and so I hope you'll
come find me if something in here you
think Mike relate the things that you're
doing and I'd be happy to follow up and
so and you know look at joint project
opportunities and other things so please
come find me and hopefully this would be
a teaser for more in-depth interactions
throughout the time I'm here
Tuesdays through Thursdays most weeks
between now and the end of March and so
find me soon and then in April and and
May much less often because I have to
teach back down at Cal Tech okay so let
me start by just saying a little bit
about what what is control the problem
with the word is it's a broad word it
gets used all over the place it gets
used in lots of different ways so for
people doing feedback control theory
what do we mean by control and sort of
the traditional point of view would be
something like this you have some system
that you want to control maybe it's
autonomous vehicle this is an autonomous
vehicle that was entered in the DARPA
Grand Challenge built 500 Caltech
undergraduates named Alice and so among
other things one of the things Alice is
supposed to be able to do is drive at a
constant speed when commanded so drive
at 25 miles an hour down the road or
down the dirt road or it is and so a
typical feedback control law for doing
that would be to sense what the vehicles
compare that to what the desired speed
is so compute what you want to do I want
to speed up where I want to slow down
and then to actuate the system press the
gas pedal press the brake whichever has
to be and to do this in some sort of a
feedback loop and so you know you know
starting class we would say well control
is really about sensing actuation and
computation in some sort of a feedback
loop and the idea being that now we want
that closed loop system to have some
desired behavior or something else and
the typical things that we look at our
stability that is that I would like that
small perturbations either stay small or
better yet converge back to the desired
equilibrium point performance I like
that when I command a different speed so
I say go from 25 miles an hour to 35
miles an hour that I do so in a way in
which it's smooth and it's relatively
quick and it feels good and all those
good things so we have to have
performance measures and then perhaps
most importantly robustly that means
that in the face of uncertainty maybe
the tank is full maybe it's not full
maybe the car is one year old maybe it's
10 years old maybe it's got two people
in it maybe it's got ten people in it
I'd like it to operate the same across
all of those different conditions and so
the ideas are to look at stability which
is in some sense the easiest of those
performance but really robust stability
and robust performance or the
interesting part so how do I have those
properties be robust with respect to
some source of uncertainty so in the
traditional view that's it and you know
you can spend a lot of time talking
about how to do those things but in fact
the the field is changing in a think
quite exciting way and so the emerging
point of view is a little bit different
and so you know the emerging point of
view we go from the sort of applications
on the left which are you know kind of
aircraft and building controllers and
things like that to the applications on
the right which are you know autonomous
cars and biological systems the internet
you know very large enterprise scale
systems this one is a battlespace
management system and we think about
control as the collection of tools and
techniques for analyzing designing and
implementing complex systems in the
presence of uncertainties so the
uncertainty is still there and it's a
combination of thinking about dynamics
so dynamics of the underlying process as
well as dynamics of the feedback control
system interconnections and feedback and
feed-forward in particular
and communications computing in software
which is how we implement all of those
things and so I think a more modern view
if you looked at a control system you
might see something and I'll put this up
in more detail later and we'll kind of
walk through some of the pieces that
looks like some relatively complicated
block diagram at multiple levels of
abstraction with all sorts of things
going on and this is sort of what's
going on inside of an autonomous car
these days in terms of all of the
computing that's going on the different
things that have to be managed and so
I'd say a more modern view of control
then would be that it's some sort of
product right of dynamics and
uncertainty and feed-forward and
feedback and so you know someone says
what's control about all of us when all
of these things come together that's
what the field tries to understand and
so you can remember this by the acronym
Duff so if you're a Simpsons fan just
think Duff Beer and that will remind you
dynamics uncertainty feed-forward and
feedback okay so there are a couple of
key principles that guide the way that
we think about control systems and these
have been constant over time both for
the kind of traditional view but also
this more modern view and the first of
those is that feedback is a tool for
managing uncertainty uncertainty in your
system but also uncertainty in the
environment so not only may the system
be changing the age of the car the power
of the car the weight of the car and
other things but the environment might
be changing I might be on a dirt road or
it might be on a highway or I might be
on something that's bumpy or smooth and
again I'd like to use feedback as a way
of managing that uncertainty the other
thing is that feedback provides us a
tool for designing the dynamics of a
system oh and sorry let me say if
there's no uncertainty so if you say my
system is well known it's completely
characterized you don't need feedback
all right so don't bother with it but if
it has uncertainty then feedback is one
of the tools there are others as well
the other principle is that it provides
feedback and feed-forward provide tools
for design of dynamics that is that we
can design the dynamics to be different
than the natural dynamics of the system
so for example an aircraft that might
normally be unstable like that one in
the lower left right the wings are
pointed forward you can imagine if you
tilt it up a little bit right that it
flips over right but with feedback we
can make that have desirable properties
so that it flies like a regular aircraft
fly is like a very stable aircraft or
something like that so feedback is a
mechanism for designing the dynamics
system to achieve something you wanted
to achieve and it's a mechanism for
handling uncertainty and making
something robust with respect to the
uncertainty and the two of these
together designing the dynamics and
managing uncertainty provide I think one
of the powerful kind of corollaries of
these which is that feedback enables
modularity and interoperability
I think modularity because now I can
interconnect it two different things and
because it's robust with respect to what
its interconnected to and because the
dynamics right are something that I
designed to do that in face of that
robustness right I get a module alright
they can be interconnected two different
things and operate in the same way yeah
other dimensionalities yeah so in some
sense I'll try and say you know that
generally one wants to look at all sorts
of different types of feedback right
sort of temporal feedback but also
potential spatial feedback so something
might happen differently when I move
over here versus over there all right or
other types and I'll try and get into
some of the different ways that we think
about them okay so in a very very high
level control is about this kind of set
of things and there been some important
things that have happened in the last 15
years or so just to keep in the back of
your mind about where's this field going
and what are the tools and what are
people doing with it and so one of these
is that just like every other field the
massive increases the amount of
computation we have available have
changed what we can do and so we've gone
from minimum finding controllers on
little you know bespoke analog circuits
and things like that to implement the
implementing things in microprocessors
and more complicated you know Nvidia
processors and other things and so on
line optimization is something we can do
so what this experiment is showing you
is something where we're actually
calculating out trajectories for this
flight control system and we are
calculating every tenth of a second what
to do for the next second or two and
then doing that for a tenth of a second
and then recomputing and then
recomputing and then recomputing right
and doing so write all of this
recomputation is a mechanism of feedback
this is something called receding
horizon control I'll give you more
detail in a minute but it allows us to
deal with highly non-linear systems in
very constrained environments and allows
for
really quite aggressive types of
trajectories and other things that can
be very robust and just to say this is
now something from you know probably a
little bit more than 15 years ago at the
time we implemented it it took 30
thousand dollars worth of computing to
implement that right it's of course less
than the amount of computing on your
cell phone today right and so this is
the type of thing that is all over the
place feedback control systems use
optimization all the time yeah we'll
give me a give me a second I'll get to
it and so you know I'll talk about it
okay so optimization advances in
computing big deal another is just
thinking about you know computer science
and layering and different layers of
abstraction this is showing a video from
the DARPA Grand Challenge this is a
Celtic undergraduate team that designed
a vehicle that could drive on roads here
you're seeing it navigating a stop sign
intersection this is from 2007 so about
a decade before the search of things you
see now it doesn't know exactly where
the road is it's having to take sensory
data make computations and do things but
it's doing it at multiple layers of
abstraction it has to worry about
staying on the road and driving the
right speed but it also story about what
are these cars in front of me
what whose turn is it at the
intersection should I go now or not
right and things at a different level of
kind of discrete decision-making and so
these are very complicated systems and
these complicated systems we break up in
the usual way into different layers of
abstraction and different components and
put them together another advance has
been again taking things coming from
computer science using ideas from formal
methods this is an area where I'm
particularly active and taking ideas
from computer science about verification
and synthesis using temporal logics and
other things and applying these to
control systems I'm gonna run a video
over here on the right and what you're
gonna see is a discrete decision-making
system where I have a bunch of incoming
robots and they are supposed to get
blocked by the robots down at the bottom
this is sort of like a soccer you know
you block you and you know you tag the
you this other person type of a set up
and the idea is that there's now a
protocol that's running on the bottom
that is going to switch assignments
right by talking to the neighbor on the
left and the right and if I see that I'm
going for somebody on this side and
you're going for somebody on this side
it would make sense for us to switch and
so we're going to implement a
feedback algorithm that is going to talk
to each other and somehow figure out
whether or not we can switch and as it
does so it will always resolve out so
that there are no crosses and we can
always block people before they come
down and we'd like to prove that that
works and it's robust with respect to
the dynamics of the the incoming agents
etc but this is now a discrete problem
rather than some you know what speed
should you go right it should I be a
sign to probably know to agent one or
agent two I mean so it's a different
style of problem and finally the other
big trend has been just moving up in
scale and so Internet of Things types of
pictures where we really think about
doing enterprise level control and so
certainly one the early ones of those
was just internet congestion control
that was an enterprise level system but
now when you look at supply chains and
when you look at battlespace management
you look at all of these other very
large scale systems these are examples
where controls are coming in ok so
that's kind of at a high level the sorts
of things we'd like to think about and
of course what I want to do is dive in
and tell you answer what is feed-forward
what does feedback but also some of the
techniques that we're using
so here's what I'm going to try and
cover the you know in this first lecture
and then after a break in the second one
so I'll try and go through all of this
and we'll see how far I get but I'll
start by just talking about the kind of
standard model for control what's the
control architecture that we think about
and try and give a couple of examples of
how that architecture can be applied to
real time decision-making then talk
about some of the standard design
patterns that are used in control if you
go look inside the hood of a control
system you'll see typically a couple of
different design patterns and then talk
about feedback systems and then
feed-forward systems and so what do I
mean by those two things and how do we
use them and then as I have time I'll
talk a little bit about now as we layer
the architecture and look at these more
complex systems what does that look like
and then talk some about reactive
protocols these discrete decision-making
protocols okay so that's what I'm going
to try and cover please feel free to
interrupt me and I'll try and stop at
the end of each slide as I start to do a
little bit more technical things and say
questions I mean if I don't just raise
your hand or yell something else okay so
let's talk about this kind of standard
model right so if physics has a standard
model here's the control system standard
so we start with some input output
process so you've got some process it's
got inputs and outputs it might be your
car and the input is your gas and
steering and the output is the speed
you're going in your location it might
be a big computer farm right and the
input is how many computers should I be
running and the output is how much
computation can I do it might be this
building and I can turn on or off the
air-conditioning or the heating right
anything that you can think of that I
have some set of inputs that will
typically change the behavior of the
process and I have something that I can
observe about that process and so we
want to look at that class of systems
the first thing we need to do is the
things that we observe may or may not be
the things that we care about that is
the system may have internal state we
may care about what that internal state
is but we can only see what we can see
you see what we can measure and so there
a first thing we'll do is we'll put an
observer on this and that observer will
watch the outputs of the system and
infer something about the system and
indeed some of the scientific
applications that we heard about on
Monday right where you want to see a
supernova or you want to know whether an
earthquake occurred right I know what
the input for an earthquake is right you
know something down deep in the core but
you're watching a bunch of cellphones
shake up and down right and you like to
say did an earthquake happen or not
right and so you want an observer that
is trying to watch the signal which is a
bunch of things going up and down and
infer something about the underlying
process which is you know the San
Andreas just erupted get out of town or
whatever it is so will typically have
some sort of an observer that we use and
of course that observer is the the the
observation process is complicated by
the fact that there's often noise
involved so I don't get a clean
measurement all right in addition to not
necessarily measuring what I want to
measure there may also be noise on that
so the cellphones we're all moving
around and jumping up and down on other
things and that's corrupting things
right we got to look for the
correlations between
everything going on now on the other end
on the input end we'll typically put our
controller and so the idea of the
controller is I take some sort of a
description of the task I'd like to
drive down the road at 25 miles an hour
I'd like to have the building be 30
degrees C or 25 degrees C and then I'm
going to command the inputs I'm going to
turn on and off the air conditioners I'm
going to press the gas I'm going to
start up more
compute servers whatever it happens to
be so I have some description of my
tasks and the controller's job is to
take that task description and decide
what inputs to apply to the process to
somehow get that to satisfy that task
and to some extent the simplest control
system would look just like this and if
I had a perfect model of the process
alright I can just kind of invert it
outright I can say okay I know what the
heat capacity of this room is and how
much heat you're all generating I know
what the temperature outside is so I can
figure out how much heat do I need to
put it in this room to keep it at some
temperature how much heat do I need to
take out and then I'll just do that all
right and so if I have all of the
information than I can do that and we
typically call this open-loop control
because I'm not gonna see whether I'm
right or not I'm just going to right
sort of put something in you can think
about open-loop control lots of
different ways a typical stoplight would
be open-loop control if it doesn't use a
traffic sensor he's just gonna say look
I'm just gonna turn my light cycling
right every two minutes all right I'm
gonna give different directions right
the ability to go probably more often
than two minutes and that's it right and
if you're doing that in a mobility
situation that may or may not optimize
the mobility but it's a pretty simple
schedule right and so we're not going to
measure anything we're just gonna do
that now part of the reason that's
complicated of course is that what you
tell the system to do and what the
system actually does may be different so
there are some sort of disturbances that
come in right so I don't really know the
temperature outside or somebody in here
is burning a lot more heat or somebody
plugged their laptop in and that's
generating more power than I knew and so
these disturbances make it hard to use
just open-loop control and get the
desired output and so it's at this point
that we start using feedback we say look
but I can measure what the temperature
in this room is or I can measure what
the traffic is right and I can use that
to decide whether or not I want to do
things and so the feedback loop or a
closed loop system right comes from
taking some output from the observer and
then feeding that back and making some
decision in the controller that is going
to affect the process which is going to
change the output all right which is
then going to affect the processes I'm
gonna get some sort of a cycle and so
the idea of course is to try and design
that in a way that gives the desired
performance and so now
for example if there are disturbances
and I let's say I'm doing a car
controller and I'm trying to hold the
speed constant I say well I know for
this car that if I push the gas down
this much I should go 35 miles an hour
but now I started going up a slight hill
I'll measure that I'm going to slow
alright now I can say oh well push the
gas a little bit more and that should
speed me up a little bit I come over the
top of the hill I let it off right all
of those things and of course we have to
be careful because this can lead to
instability right so if I for example
see that I'm going a little bit too slow
it's like push the gas really hard well
now I'll go too fast now I'm going too
fast so I'll pull back right we've all
maybe less so now but probably all been
in cars where somebody's not very good
at this right and that kind of you know
you get really sick really quickly right
and so you know they're not as good a
feedback controllers who might like
nowadays cruise controllers are really
good right you set it at 55 miles an
hour you go 55 miles an hour you go up a
hill you probably won't even see a
deviate off of 55 miles an hour right I
mean they really kind of do the right
thing okay so that's one way of thinking
about feedback is that we have this
process we have disturbances and noise
we want to be robust with respect to
those disturbances and noise and we we
have we'd like to accomplish our task
now there's another yeah sure
I'd say a little bit of both so you know
part of what happens is the sensors got
better so we can sense speed much more
accurately part of it is that the it
used to be that you know if you look at
a really old car it would be implemented
as a mechanical cruise controller I mean
is actually am a kind of
electromechanical system and that had
its limitations in what it can do and
modern computation can do more and so we
can measure things better and yeah I'd
say that's probably most of it and you
know the everything is electronically
controlled now so you don't have to go
through a mechanical process and things
like that so I'm gonna I'm gonna expand
on this box and tell you what's inside
it that's where all of the you know kind
of control theory is happening in some
sense some on the right-hand side as
well it for the estimation algorithms
and other things but at a high level
right lots of things could go in there
absolutely
including feed-forward feedback
different types of computation whether
it's electromechanical that are all fit
in that little box now there's one other
important part that that control theory
has developed now it's it is
traditionally been a very model-based
field that is you give me a model of the
process you give me a model of what the
disturbances and the noise are usually
just bounds on those all right so I know
how much win there is I know what the
airplane is gonna get moved around by
things like that and then I will come up
with my controller but one of the things
we all know about models is models are
always approximations they're there to
answer certain questions and they're
never going to be exact for every
question and so one of the things that
happened early in control theory is that
people thought about what if your model
isn't right
and so often you'll see in a control
diagram this little extra piece added up
on the top that it's some sort of
uncertainty and the the idea here is
that that box up there just like the
other boxes here might be a dynamic
input output map that is it might
actually have dynamics in it so one
thing we might think about for example
is if you're designing a flight
controller for an airplane then of
course you design this flight controller
you say well you know if I want to turn
left I need to kind of you know move my
flaps around other things so that I turn
left and then fly around right and so my
process might have those
rigid body mechanics in it that give me
that with a little bit of the
aerodynamics of hey you know if I tilt
one of the ailerons or other things a
certain amount how much force will I get
in all those things but of course
there's a lot of other things going on
right the wings are actually flexible
they're not rigid right so if you look
out the if you're sitting in a wing seat
right you look outside and you're like
in turbulence or something you can see
the wings are moving right and so does
that matter or not I mean there's fuel
in those wings and that feels sloshing
around it's a liquid right has dynamics
right as you're moving around and
getting bucked around all that fuel
sloshing around does that matter or not
and so we'll typically put up into that
box that I've labeled environment but
really should have probably labeled
uncertainty unmodeled dynamics right
that is we know their dynamics that
we're leaving out and we're going to
take that into account in our design and
we're going to bound that so I'm not
saying anything can happen
I'm gonna say look I know that on my
wings you know if I move my rigid body
around a little bit I could excite those
modes but I've got some model for I
don't expect the wings to bend more than
a certain amount or to bend you know
more than at higher frequencies than
something-or-other and so I can put
bounds on what that unmodeled set of
dynamics are but I'm not going to assume
that I have all of the dynamics I'm
gonna allow for unmodeled dynamics
disturbances as well as noise so those
are the sources of uncertainty okay
so in this kind of Couture diagram there
are a couple of key elements so one is
there's the process some sort of an
input/output system that has memory or
dynamics to it we care about things
where if I make a change now that will
affect me for some period of time if I
turn the heater on right it will take
some amount of time until the room heats
up and it'll take some amount of time
before it cools back down we also care
about the environment and so I've drawn
this little line just to sort of say the
stuff up on the top is the description
of the uncertainty present in the system
or its environment right so there's some
sort of unmodeled nameks disturbances
and noise that's going to typically be
bounded but not specified directly I'm
not gonna the whole point is I'm going
to kind of ignore that from the point of
view of the design and then show I'm
robust with respect to it later
the third piece of course is this
observer over here on the right and so
we have to estimate the states that we
care about the underlying system state
that we care about from what we can
measure and then of course the stuff on
the left right which is the actual
controller that we're going to do and so
this is where we're going to try and
achieve the desired task by taking the
data that we get from the observer and
the known actions that we can apply to
the process so that's the sort of
standard picture for control and of
course the part that we think a lot
about in the control theory community
right is now colored in blue this
feedback part all right so it's a it's a
feedback cycle and you have to be
careful how you reason about things
because you know the changes you make of
the controller affect the process which
affects what you observe which affects
what you do in the controller right so
there's a cycle and there are things
that could go wrong it in particular
implementing feedback systems is often
painful and there are three primary
disadvantages I would say one is it's
kind of complicated because you got
putting in extra sensors and actuators
and other things you have a potential
for instability whenever you have
feedback so you know a standard one is
the microphone if I turn the gain up too
much it'll squeal right that's an
instability that's occurring because
it's going around this loop and getting
amplified and amplified and amplified
until we hit the saturation and then
furthermore even if it's not unstable
you can still amplify the noise that is
if I have a noisy sensor all right then
I might try and respond to that noisy
sensor even though that's not really
what the system is doing right so if I
don't have a very accurate speed
controller for example and it's drifting
around all I know is that's the speed
I'm reading and so I'll follow that so
these are not good things to have happen
and so to some extent if you can avoid
using feedback you should but there are
reasons why you might want to use it and
I'd say the two primary advantages are
that it provides robustness with respect
to uncertainty because you measure what
actually happens right not what you
think happens and then it enables
through the design of the dynamics as
well as this robustness to uncertainty
modularity and interoperability so you
know every large-scale engineering
system involves feedback someplace right
your body involves feedback all over the
place
ecosystems have feedback on everything
and all these things and part of it is
that it's trying to be robust with
respect to uncertainty and provide some
set of modular interoperability okay so
this is my you know if if you talk to
somebody controller and you draw this
diagram they all say yep I get it you
know that's exactly what we study and
the generality is this process can be
the Earth's climate this process can be
discrete decisions that are happening
inside of an algorithm that's doing
Bitcoin mining these that process can be
you know sort of lots of things as long
as it's got inputs outputs and sub
dynamics - okay so questions about this
if I haven't lost everybody already
still high level I'm going to go more
detail but just a conceptually this is
what we think about as it's kind of the
standard model for control theory
okay all right so now let's just look at
this a little bit and I'll try and do
just a couple of examples so let's look
at some of the things that we've already
heard about and say well how do they fit
in this diagram so we heard on Monday
about a couple of different things
earthquake detection and supernova
detection those fit into this diagram
but maybe in a simplified way there's to
my knowledge no actuator for supernovae
at least not one that we control all
right
yet the specification what are we trying
to do what we're trying to detect them
right it's an estimation problem
observer problem right and so really
it's just this observer only earthquakes
are a little more interesting might say
well earthquakes are the same we're just
trying to detect them but actually we
can actuate earthquakes fracking
actually actuates earthquakes I mean
this is known and there's no reason why
in principle I can't say well look we're
doing fracking maybe we should measure
what the seismometer say and right
before we see the big one about to
happen right maybe we should you know do
about your fracking in certain spots
right to try and keep that from
happening maybe right so I don't know
for now right as observers only we're
not trying to control earthquakes yet
but maybe someday okay so these are I
would put these in the class of things
that maybe we'll call kind of scientific
detection right it is certainly
potentially a real-time decision making
problem but it's one in which mainly we
wanted to detect events we have sensors
and there's an observer so it fits but
you know the feedback loops in there so
control theories not going to help very
much here right maybe in an auxilary way
now we saw yesterday a bunch of
applications around the ideas of
mobility right urban mobility bike share
car share right these are very
interesting because they are feedback
control systems right so for example if
we look at something like bike share
right what's the actuator well you get
to move the bikes around all right you
got to go pick them up right we're empty
we're gonna go pick them up right what
is what's the sensor well I know where
the bikes are at least which docks
they're in right I maybe know something
about the apps that you know somebody
says they want to use one or not right
depending on and we had this discussion
about yesterday what am I trying to
achieve well I want to optimize their
location and usage right I want to make
sure I don't go down to zero I want to
make sure that it got enough docks to
put them in right all the stuff we heard
about yesterday
and this of course fits in this I would
say unless you're doing dynamic
management it's not at the fastest time
scale right that is typically and the
people who talked about this can tell me
more you know you probably think about
having an open-loop schedule right you
know the trucks going to drive around
it's gonna pick up this many bikes a
little from this place and put it there
and not something that's dynamic I see
that I have too many bicycles here so
let me send the trucks out right now and
start adjusting them around but you
could do that right we could also start
and we talked about this yesterday and
some of the questions incentivizing
things all right hey I'll give you five
bucks off you go park your bicycle over
there instead of over here all right
because of what I want to do I want to
get the closed-loop to put the bicycles
in the right place at the right time and
my actuator now right is probably less
known when these other ones incentives
all right so I can use that too so we
can think of that as a feedback system
and you know we saw yesterday some
examples of things where they were just
horrendous dynamics right I mean really
bad right because it was going down to
zero and it's going all over the place
right you know I would argue it's not a
very good feedback system all right in
what's implemented might because we
don't have good actuators right right
because we don't have good sensors right
might just be because we haven't
actually thought of it as a feedback
system and tried to stabilize right in a
better way what's going on okay so those
are I think interesting applications
where where maybe the ideas from control
apply certainly there's uncertainty
there right we don't know exactly who's
gonna go where when we don't know when
the bicycles are gonna break right if
it's right chair we don't know exactly
what the traffic's gonna look like
etcetera etcetera
okay so these transportation networks
then have things like schedules and
incentives as their actuators some sort
of demand measurements and supply
measurements perhaps in in what they
sense they're trying to optimize some
sort of utility function I think they're
open-loop at the fast time scales what
happens over the course of minutes or
days or hours they're closed-loop at a
slower rate that is we adjust the number
of bicycles that we pre position we
adjust the number of racks right so at a
weekly time scale we might have some
closed-loop stuff okay a third one and
this is actually what I'll talk about
next week in the public lecture if you
come on Tuesday is autonomous vehicles
and I already showed you a little bit of
that so here of course you can think
about the actuators just as the gas in
the steering the sensors are all sorts
of cameras and radars and laser
rangefinders and other things but also
measurements of the traffic
and other information that we might get
from the cloud what are we trying to do
well roughly we're trying to get from A
to B without hitting anyone right and by
the way a smooth ride and you know
minimize fuel and a bunch of other
things but probably the first one that
is get from A to B without hitting
anyone and it's a very interesting very
complex environment I'll tell you a
little bit more about you know some of
the architectures that used for them
okay so these are examples that we saw
that at least the top two classes
already and we'll see more tomorrow when
we hear about the smart grid and other
things right examples where there are
feedback and and uncertainties and other
things and so maybe the tools from
control theory you can apply okay and
then I'll just say a little bit about
and you know through this asked already
what types of systems can one do and so
I'd say this is kind of three broad
classes and lots of intersections you
know one is if we have continuous States
temperature altitude speed things like
that and we model those with ordinary
differential equations or partial
differential equations or difference
equations if it's something that's on a
discrete-time clock and typically the
specifications there might be integrated
cost over time or space so we can think
about spatial as the free variable and
these are very well studied systems and
there are lots of tools available
particularly for linear time-invariant
systems so if I have a linear
differential equation a linear partial
differential equation a linear
difference equation then I can apply a
lot more mathematics to that and sort of
do things so this is sort of the classic
area that if you take a class in control
theory you'll almost certainly study
this class one can also think though and
I'll talk more about this at the end
about discrete state systems okay so now
I can turn something on or off or I can
turn left or right and so I have
discrete decisions that I can make so
now the dynamics are going to be
described by some sort of a finite state
automata probably some sort of an
input-output finite state automata maybe
time to tomat are depending on how time
comes in their Petri Nets and other
types of representations and lots of
different ways you can represent these
discrete state systems if it's a
manufacturing system and I say how many
parts do I have right there's a discreet
number right we can do as we saw
yesterday a little bit we can do
continuous approximations of those so I
can start looking at densities of parts
and other things and pop them up into my
top class right by choosing a different
model but some of them really if I want
to turn left or right
it's probably going to be something at
this level our specifications might be
written in some sort of a temporal logic
and again I'll say a little bit more
about that later and here I'd say
they're great tools for doing
verification that is given a design does
it satisfy the specifications less good
tools for doing design and synthesis how
do I actually design those and make sure
they work now all of the things that
I've said so far I've been in some sense
a kind of deterministic point of view
and many of the things I particularly
work on we use a sort of deterministic
point of view but what can also have a
probabilistic point of view all right so
you can say look you know it's a
stochastic system maybe it's you know
represented by a stochastic OTE or a
coma grab equation or some sort of a
Markov decision process and and now my
specifications are probably things like
this but in terms of probabilities
expected moments right things of that
sort and again it's relatively well
studied especially for things like
linear time invariant systems Markov
decision processes there's lots of tools
around all of these fit you know kind of
in this picture of things going on and
the same principles apply that is you
want to manage uncertainty and design
dynamics right and use the feedback to
do that all right so let me say a little
about well so let me here's some
different types of things I gave some
examples I'll just pause briefly
questions about the types of things we
can model or think of as a control
system and the various components of it
you have disturbances and noise and
environment that represents unmodeled
dynamics what happens when you have an
adversarial environment yeah great
question so you can think of that in a
number of different ways so one is I
would say adversarial can be captured in
that little environment box up there and
you can think of it now as a game right
that is the environment gets to see what
I'm doing that's the arrow coming in to
it it then gets to decide what it's
gonna do and it could have a different
objective function to keep me from
getting to you know my point and then it
gets to inject something back if I can
put some sort of a bound on what's
possible it fits the theory all right
now the other thing say look you know
the other cars that are on the road
let's pretend they're trying to keep me
from getting someplace they still have
to satisfy physics if it's two miles
away I don't have to worry about
interacting with it in the next 30
seconds right I guess what I'm going
really fast so but anyway so you know I
think you can still put it into that
framework of course I have to tell you
now that my model of the environment is
adversarial and they might be working
against you the things that are coming
in is disturbances and noise we should
think of those as more benign they're
not measuring what I'm doing and trying
to subvert me so adversarial stuff would
go in that env box an adversarial
environment imagine there are situations
say in the driving situation there's a
there's a tight loop for ignition one
supporter meets once a year it's right
how people play should be so so there's
there's at least in this case kind of a
nesting but is it fruitful to consider
there being some kind of an algebra for
composing goose yeah it's a great
question so so let me first talk about
the nesting and then talk about the
mathematical searchers so the nesting
level absolutely we see this all the
time right so let's do manufacturing you
know at the manufacturing level there's
a robot someplace that has very tight
loops that are controlling you know I'm
gonna put this in this position right
there's something else is saying well
I've got to get the parts to wear that
robot can pick it up that's happening at
a slower time scale over the next couple
of minutes there's something that's
saying I got to ship the parts to the
factory so if they get there there's
somebody who's saying I got to make a
new contract with another supplier right
every quarter there's a board that's
saying you know we're gonna get out of
this business so that these are all
feedback loops happening at different
scales we do talk about and I'll show
you this at least schematically and they
have to talk more about it how do you do
what we'd call vertical contracts
between those right because the bottom
one is implementing some desired
dynamics the top one is making some
assumptions about that that is that when
the people worrying about shipping or
thinking about you know are the right
parts gonna be here at cetera they're
not worried about the currents going
through the motors on the robots that
are putting those things together nor
should they have to they should simply
know that the robots will put them
together at this rate so there are
different abstractions but I need to
make sure that the assumptions that I'm
making about what the upper layer is
thinking
and when I'm doing our consistent so
there is a contract structure I would
say making that into more of an
algebraic structure I think would be
interesting to think about and could
probably be done I think the hard part
would be often the layers of abstraction
are using different mathematics and so
now you've got a you know I don't know
it's a category theory or something
weird writing you got to get into
something where you're really talking
about generalized classes of algebras
right because if I'm doing discrete
variables in one spot I'm doing
continuous variables over time and
another and continuous variables over
space and another space good so let me
use that to then introduce the next
thing so what are the specifications
that we're trying to satisfy what's
what's the problem we're trying to solve
right so let me say a little if I don't
answer it ask again so let me just give
you some examples of the types of
problems that we're trying to solve and
again this comes back to the different
layers and what you're doing right so a
very typical one will be a regulation
problem that is I'm trying to regulate
the speed of the vehicle or the position
of the aircraft or something like that
and for those we would often do
something and sorry I'm going to have to
use some math that I haven't introduced
but we would do something where we say
well I have an input-output mapping and
this input output mapping is now going
to be written in terms of operators and
so I've got some output Y that's the
thing that I measure I have some input U
and some disturbance D those are the
inputs that I had and I'm going to
assume that there's some relation
between these and here I've written it
in terms of a linear system a Laplace
transforms but just think of these as
operators right I've got some operator
Pyu that take some function U and gives
the component the the output that would
go along with that this addition might
be a more complicated interconnection
right that besides just addition but
I've got some disturbance D and I need
to tell you something about the
disturbances so for example I might say
they're bounded in some way right now I
have a certain amount of energy and the
disturbances or something like that
and the problem that we want to solve if
we were writing it as a control theorist
we might write it like this which is
complete Greek so let me write it in
terms of pictures so for example we
might care about what are the transients
to the system that is if I tell you to
change speed from 25 miles an hour to 35
miles an hour I mean how do you respond
to that and so for example we might talk
about that would be one that would be a
traditional step response so I give you
some step input I'd like you to go from
you know zero to one and the system will
respond and that system responds if it's
a continuous variable in continuous-time
might for example have a little bit of
oscillation or something else and you
can imagine the specifications would be
well I don't like the large amount of
oscillation like this is I'm changing
the speed and you go too fast and you
slow down and finally you settle in to
the right speed that's not desirable so
we might have things like the rise time
how long does it take to get to the
right speed the overshoot how much over
speed do you go before you come back
down the settling time that is how long
does it take you to get within plus or
minus 1% and stay there so I might get
up to the speed but I overshoot it and
then I come down right and so these are
all the types of metrics that we might
use these are now cost functions and I
can now ask can I design the controller
to give those to give good
characteristics another thing that we
worry about a lot is not the transience
how do I respond to something changing
but the steady-state response so
steady-state response often comes up
when we have something where the
transients have died out and I'm now
into some steady operation think of this
as some cyclical motion that I'm
commanding and so there's some initial
transient and then I settle into that
cyclical motion and so often we'll talk
about for example the frequency response
if it's a system in continuous variables
where I say well if I have let's say
sinusoidal disturbances at some
frequency the wind is blowing right and
it's blowing at some frequency then how
much do i amplify or attenuate I mean
blowing and so for example if I'm a
bridge and the wind is blowing in a
certain speed and it's setting up
certain periodic types of forcing I
might say well if that periodic forcing
is that you know frequency 10 to the
minus 1 Hertz or radians per second I
get some response right there's maybe a
little bit of a resonance as I get to a
higher forcing frequency right and then
it dies down so we look at the gain from
some input whether it's my control input
or my disturbance to my output then I
can write what the gain is and what the
phase is the phase lag and a sinusoidal
response and I want to do this in steady
state after the transients have died out
so that would be another specification I
might give you specifications on these
sorts of frequency responses I don't
want any frequency to be amplified more
than a certain amount I want all
frequencies above 100 Hertz to be
attenuated by at least a factor of 10
right so those would be a different type
of specifications again we would then
try and solve that problem now these are
the sorts of specifications you see
often this kind of lowest level the
fastest loops these regulation loops and
we often have things that look a little
bit more like what we've seen where we
might say well what if what I really
want to do is that kind of open the just
planning I want to get from A to B right
and I want to maybe minimize some
integral cost function plus some
terminal cost over some fixed horizon
from x 0 to t and so I've got some
nonlinear system I have some constraints
on the states the input may be the noise
and I want to minimize some cost
function so these would be more
traditional we saw a lot of these sorts
of things for example yesterday I can
also talk about specifications that
happen not at the level of these kind of
continuous types of variables but if I
have a finite state machine alright that
is describing my input/output system
then I might get something like this so
I'll describe this if I get to it a
little bit later but this is now a
temporal logic formula that says
something about the properties of the
events that occur and the sequences of
events that occur and so here now we
might have properties that are thought
of as safety properties so for people in
computer science right what do you have
you have safety properties and live in
this property right so safety property
roughly speaking says nothing bad should
ever happen I should always stay at
least a meter away from all nearby cars
I should never run in
the curb I write they should never
happen progress properties are liveness
properties are things that should
eventually happen or should happen in a
recurring way so you should always
recharge you should always get back into
your lane if you can all right things
that you know it's not like I should
never do this it's okay to get out
transiently but I should get back
something like that so in all of these
right are things that we can try and
optimize over and so typically you know
you have to say well which of these are
you trying to optimize right and for
what reason and then what are the
designs that let you do that and so all
of these kind of come at the same time
one of the interesting things I think
about control theory and particularly
the way it's going is for the most part
these are three different communities
right this is the sort of optimization
community right this is the kind of
frequency domain operator community
coming from controls right this is the
computer science community right so you
know most people can't read everything
on the diagram right if I said you know
translate this to English right you know
it's like okay box diamond
something-or-other right you know I know
that all that means I'll tell you in a
minute right most of you probably read
this but you know what norm of my using
what are these operators what the hell
is going on right so you know again you
know at high level though we're trying
to you know do these transients
steady-state safety and liveness
properties okay so those I don't know if
that answers your question about what
problem you trying to solve here is for
three problems that you might try and
solve written in a set of mathematics
that if I'm lucky you understand one of
so so for example you know this might I
want I've started written in a zero to T
but I might want this to be really
little T to capital T so over every
horizon minimize this thing right in
these transients and steady states time
is very much there right so I want the
rise time when I get an event to within
a certain I want to respond within a
certain
oh so yeah I would say like all
engineering things right local it's good
if it's good enough right so you know
are they you know the problems I've this
problem is solvable it's convex other
things cuz I've assumed a lot of
structure this problem is not convex not
necessarily solvable but they're good
algorithms to do it right they do good
enough this is roughly the problem that
autonomous cars are solving over and
over again all the time right so we we
trust them ready to mean you know you
would go into an autonomous car so yeah
so it's true that I think of it yeah so
I could say you know I've said we can do
partial differential equations and
spatial-temporal things but I've not
said a lot about it let me just give you
an example of one which comes from
geoengineering so in geoengineering one
of the questions is can we seed clouds
all right and really the question is not
can we make it rain but where can we
make it rain and over what time right
and so one of the interesting questions
that people ask is if I did cloud
seeding types of things
how much can I control the distribution
over space of where the rain will occur
right can I make it rain every place
where there are fields and farms and
other things or do I not have that much
spatial control so that would be one
where now you're trying to integrate a
cost function over some you know it's
going to be high cost over regions in
which you know high costs for no rain
and regions in which you have crops
right so it can be done got harder
because you got your PDS instead of over
two E's and things like that okay so let
me kind of describe a couple of design
patterns and what I'm gonna do is I want
to go into these in detail so I'm gonna
kind of show you what the standard
patterns are and then I'm gonna explain
I hope what's inside these a little bit
more and now this is kind of taking that
box that I just labeled C and saying
yeah but what do you do inside that box
in some sense alright so here's one
standard design pattern so I apologize
I've reused the web controller so here's
my process here's my disturbances the
noise so you recognize that part and now
I'm expanding out a little bit what's
inside that C box so this is the box
that I said controller before and what
I'm telling you now is that here what
I'm going to do is I'm going to take my
measured out
I'm going to multiply that by minus one
I'm going to take some reference so
think of this like the speed I want to
go or something like that I'm going to
possibly process that information a
little bit ignore this for a second and
then what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
compare my reference to my actual speed
I'm gonna compute an error you said you
wanted to be going 35 miles an hour
you're going 33 miles an hour you're off
by 2 miles an hour then one minute as I
take that error and I'm going to compute
on that error and I'm going to figure
out what input I should apply you're two
miles to slope press the gas pedal down
another quarter of an inch something
like that so we call this a reactive
compensation because I don't do anything
or there so the only way that my control
changes is if the output does something
different and I react to it right so if
we assume that the reference is constant
right then I will wait until I see that
I have an error before I do anything so
it's a reactive type of a controller and
these reactive controllers are very
common they can work very well the
controller is sitting here in some sense
the feedback controller is sitting here
this piece here is usually a reference
shaping box so one way to think about
that is if I tell you I want you to go
from 10 miles an hour to 65 miles an
hour right now
alright then immediately you have a 55
mile an hour error because there's no
way you're speeding up immediately
now if you give the controller a 55 mile
an hour error say holy cow all right I
am NOT going nearly fast enough florid
right you're just push the gas down as
hard as you can that's a stupid thing to
do what you probably really meant was if
I tell you I want to go 55 miles an hour
I'd like you to ramp up to that speed
over the next 10 or 20 seconds or
something like that so it'll be much
easier for a reactive controller if you
don't try and get it to react to these
huge changes but give it something
that's a little bit smoother right and
so we do this pre shaping of the input
in order to do them so this pre shaping
and the inputs very simple it's usually
just like a low-pass filter all right
that just makes it so that the high
frequency stuff doesn't get in there
okay so these reactive compensation
schemes then they use reference input
shaping they have a feedback that's on
the output error between the reference
and the output the compensator dynamics
that's sort of what's sitting in here or
what shape the closed
response we have uncertainty in the
disturbances noise and I've left it off
but you know implicitly whenever you see
control systems talk assume that there's
a little box around this guy
that's the unmodeled dynamics because we
always think about that in the back of
our heads and here the goals are the
standard goals we'd like it to be stable
that is that if I get noise or
disturbances and those go away I want to
return to my initial operating point I'd
like it to have good performance so for
example if I do make a change in the
reference I track that well and I'd like
it to be robust I'd like it to work even
if this model isn't exactly right in
presence of noise and presence of
disturbances so this reactive design
pattern is probably the most used design
pattern and to this question earlier
about you know why are things getting
better now this reactor design pattern
made a lot of sense when you had
relatively simple electronics and you
couldn't do a lot of computation because
you just kind of looked at the error and
then you kind of multiply that by
something and then kind of fed it back
and you'll see that in a second a more
modern and more complicated design
pattern is this one you can
automatically see it's more complicated
all right so the process is still here
disturbances noise all looks the same
but now I've really expanded out what
I'm doing here so first off the observer
is here I had that over on the other
side but you know I've sort of wrapped
it around a little bit and now what I'm
doing is something different so let's
kind of walk through this so this
trajectory generation bit is a more
sophisticated version of this reference
shaping so what I'm going to do now is
you're going to give me the task
description and I'm actually going to
compute here's what you should do based
on a model of the car what the road type
is you know what my current gas prices
are whatever you want I'm going to do a
pretty sophisticated calculation to
optimize one of those cost functions and
then I'm going to give you two things
I'm going to say based on what I saw
here is the state that I think you
should be at right to follow to carry
out this task and here is the nominal
input that you should apply in order to
do that then what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take my process I'm going to
observe if this has sorry if this
process has some internal state X the
position speed acceleration whatever is
required to describe the state I'm going
to observe that state and I'm going to
say what is the actual state of the
process compared to where I think it
should be based on this complex
calculation that I did and that's gonna
form my error this is not the output
error but the state
so the state of the system might be for
example for a car its position in the
lane its side velocity in the lane its
forward velocity right those three
things and then I'm going to put some
feedback in here so this is just like
the C of s but it's on the state error
and I'm going to add that to the nominal
input and so the way to think about this
is if the model were perfect and the
trajectory generation module knew that
model then I would exactly know and
calculate what input to apply for you to
follow that and I wouldn't need to do
anything but the model is not perfect
and they're disturbances and noise so I
also put in this feedback compensation
bit right it corrects for that but it
doesn't have to correct for everything
and you ask you know why are these
things so much better now well part of
it is that they can do this feed-forward
calculation so we call this a
feed-forward calculation FF 4
feed-forward or I can say you know look
I know what the engine dynamics are so I
know if I press the gas that's hard
right this is what I can do and so if
you tell me to speed up it will speed up
very smoothly and other things
furthermore I might even say well I see
that I am slowing down and I'm guessing
based on my GPS that I'm actually on a
hill right and so I'll press it down a
little bit further they typically don't
do that in cars they do that in trucks
and trains and things like that that is
they pre compute right here's how much
input I should apply based on changing
speed limits and trains for example
right and they save fuel that way so we
can do that now because that's like a
small microprocessors worth of computing
right that costs a buck right you know
not a you know thirty thousand dollar
computer right that used to cost twenty
years ago so this more complex pattern
is a kind of predictive compensation it
has still a reactive compensation in it
but it's predicting out based on some
sort of a model of the system it may
have a model of the environment right it
can have all sorts of things that can
come into it and so this is typically
what you see and so here we do explicit
computation of trajectories given a
model of the process and potentially a
model of the environment and this is for
example what an autonomous car does
right it knows where all the other cars
are it has some estimate of where
they're going to be it plans out a
trajectory and says here's what you
should do for some period of time and
then it says and here's the amount to
turn your wheel assuming I'm right and
here's the amount of pressure gas pedal
right and then if I'm wrong I don't
quite steer the right way right because
the road was a little slick or didn't
calculate something right all correct
for it right with this little feedback
we've been here and then I'm gonna say
more about this later but just to say
there's this little dashed line here
because one of the things that you
figure out very quickly is it's not that
I want to calculate this out once and
then not recalculate it right I want to
constantly recalculate it all right so
you can imagine saying oh well I want to
drive from you know here to the Berkeley
BART station or something like that let
me just pre compute right ahead of time
exactly when I'm going to turn the wheel
on how much and all of that stuff that's
a fine thing to do right except that as
soon as they get out there I'm gonna
find out the roads are wet right which
wasn't in my calculation right and so
now I know the roads are wet so I should
redo the calculation right and redo it
and redo it and redo it and so that
notion is what we do all the time and
that works because we have lots of
competition okay so that's these two
design patterns are the primary ones
what I'm going to do next is tell you
more about what go into these let me
pause and ask whether there are
questions at this point and then if
there are none I'll do one more slide
and if there are then all then we'll
take a break I'll answer them take a
break questions on these design patterns
or what I've said so far
yeah when you maybe missed something
when you do the trajectory generation it
seems like there's a lot of knowledge
that has to go into picking the
trajectory like you might think a dumb
one
or an expensive one no so
yeah so so I think there's several ways
so one is you can if you have good
models of what's going on and you have a
cost function that captures what you
want and the problem is either convex so
you've got a good algorithm that can
sort of sort through things then you
will if that model is a good one solve
out a pretty good trajectory right then
so you know if I'm driving on a dry road
and I want to know you know I need to
change lanes and things like that that's
a pretty easy problem and I can compute
that out for some problems that won't
work if I'm doing supply chain
management I may or may not have a
really good model of if I place an order
on Monday right you know how many of
these am I going to get at what time
right because I maybe I don't know what
the model is of the production facility
that's producing these and other things
right and so it may be much noisier and
you may have to rely on some reactive
thing oh I don't have enough of these I
better order more of them right now
really not have enough now I better put
it in an emergency order or any things
like that so all of those are trade-offs
one thing that's changing is that in
many situations this trajectory
generation bit is being done based on
data okay so for example if you're doing
self-driving cars you can think about
okay well I need to decide how to change
lanes well that's complicated because
there's some people on the corner over
there and there's some bicycles over
here and the person coming up behind me
is coming at this speed right but I've
collected billions of miles of data
can't I infer right the most probable
thing a human would have done right and
then use that trajectory as my nominal
trajectory right so you might be able to
do something with data and now I don't
have to I still have a model my models
my data right but I don't have an
explicit it's a physics based model or a
computing model of what's going on so
but but implicit in this is I have to
somehow be able to take my task
description and convert it into what I
think the system should do based on some
representation of some knowledge about
the system dynamics that's the point of
view
a generation I don't know you need to be
supposedly just use feedback and seems
the physical limits like you cannot
press the gas pedal it's so much you see
with some pounds on what you're like to
do responds right yeah it's a great
question so so I agree with you that you
know it's not strictly speaking feedback
control right to heaven by the name I
think increasingly we think of planning
as being part of the broader control
problem in part because of this little
dashed line here which is in fact you
rarely do planning kind of once way
ahead of time and never revisit
increasingly in many of these
applications you replan over and over
and over and that's a feedback loop
right because I plan something happens I
see what happened I replan right and so
this trajectory generation I've sort of
described it as feed-forward it's kind
of open-loop but it's not really when
you start closing the loop around this
thing now do you need it or not can you
do a purely reactive thing can you use
the upper design pattern for example or
just the part of the design pattern down
here sometimes yes and if you can it's
much less complicated you should get
away with you you can do it it gets hard
when the control task involves things
that are not right now right so think
about driving a car right you could take
a very myopic point of view and say look
you know I want to change lanes is there
anybody next to me in the lane or not
right and that's it because that's all I
know is let's say the distance to the
nearest car that distance is you know
greater than zero so I'll move over
right and of course we can all
appreciate that what you really want to
do is you want to think through where am
I going what does the road look like
ahead are there other cars down there
now you're doing planning alright so if
you're looking at something forward in
time and of course to do that I need a
model of what those other agents around
me do I mean in order to do that so the
invited some model of the environment
and propagate that model so I would say
if you can get away with just this part
you should do it I had a former student
of mine who went started his own company
and he took the controls class that I
taught me 20 years ago and he said
Richard you didn't spend
nearly enough time talking about this
because that's the way we get all our
performance right because increasingly
that's sort of you know if I need to if
I've got to give you the example he was
working on they were trying to get a
satellite that was the antenna that was
pointing in a satellite on a moving
vehicle
alright you can do that in a reactive
way that is that you could just wait and
see the signals going down and so I need
to move it back right but I know how I'm
driving the vehicle right and so I can
feed forward that information I'm about
to turn so you better turn the antenna
the other way how much you turn only use
a model to do that so I think
increasingly as computation has gotten
cheaper we've gone to the second design
pattern more and more and more ok so
there's probably a good place to take a
break and you'll tell us when we're
going to do much less